[Applause]
this is a white house concentrating on
tuesday's important state of the union
speech by the president
but it's not taking its eyes off ukraine
a point made by the vice president at an
event marking the end of black history
month today the eyes of the world are on
ukraine
and the brave people who are fighting to
protect their country
and their democracy
and their bravery
is a reminder a most recent reminder
that justice
equality and freedom
must never be taken for granted by any
of us
the us has announced a new round of
economic sanctions this time targeting
russia's central bank one senior white
house official says they want to drive
the russian economy backwards while
vladimir putin is pushing his tanks
forwards into ukraine they want to drive
up inflation drive down investment
possibilities and [ __ ] the purchasing
power of the kremlin the u.s state
department revealed it was also going
after the money and assets of those
closest to the russian leader and we are
standing up a joint task force to find
and freeze assets of sanctioned russian
companies oligarchs and other government
officials
these actions will severely impact
putin's inner circle
impede the kremlin's use of its
international reserves and limit its
ability to fund ongoing destabilizing
activities including the kremlin's war
machine in ukraine putin has increased
russia's nuclear alert level which
prompted reporters to ask the u.s
president if americans should be worried
by the threat of nuclear war he shot
that idea down with a one-word answer
one top u.s senator the head of the
intelligence committee mark warner says
he sees no immediate threat to putin's
rule in russia but the u.s is expecting
and preparing for a surge in cyber
attacks in retaliation to the actions
already approved as the fighting in
ukraine continues alan fisher al jazeera
at the white house